Katmandu residents are losing patience
with the relief effort these protesters
say the government is not doing enough
to help earthquake survivors finally
funding from the back open we haven't
had any relief we're very hungry we
haven't had anything to drink and
haven't been able to sleep this
government's done nothing down with this
government Prime Minister Sushil Koirala
spoke with quake survivors on a tour of
the city but he had little good news to
report his government acknowledges that
it's crisis management has been
inadequate that small consolation for
the hungry and thirsty monique berkley
they're giving us know something food or
so many things but we don't get anything
right now but he come just looking and
thrown away because whoever looking for
talk to something to him didn't give us
Jeff and his runaway is not good
conditions are even more desperate in
remote areas or relief supplies have
been slow to arrive this helicopter is
bringing World Food Program aid to
villages in the Gorkha district west of
Katmandu it's the first such delivery
since the quake we are hungry we have
not received any aid the UN warned that
providing clean water is becoming a
major challenge poor sanitary conditions
increase the threat of disease aid
workers say they need more of everything
more helicopters more more personnel and
certainly more relief supplies including
medical teams shelter tents water and
sanitation and food or obviously needed
now bad weather is compounding the
misery the monsoon season starts in May
but heavy rains have already started to
hinder rescue efforts